hey what's going on it's bill bird it's
time for the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
and i'm
just checking in on you
ah that was a weak one
whatever this is how [__]
crazy my schedule is i'm actually
podcasting right now while driving down
the street
unless i get into an accident and then
i'll immediately erase this so i don't
get in trouble
your honor he was podcasting
calling people [__]
and didn't see that person on the
scooter
um
it's tuesday evening man
and the tampa bay lightning pull out
game four and avoid getting swept
by what looks like the inevitable
stanley cup championed your colorado
avalanche however
there's a lot of pride in that tampa bay
lighting team
don't you forget they got 10 names on
that cup twice and i'll tell you right
now it's going to take more than a thing
or two for them to them that's not going
to roll over
you know you can bet you have bippy i
have not watched one second
of this series i'm just showing you how
easy it is
to talk mildly intelligent about sports
like i have
throughout the years i did watch the
boston red sox tonight win their seventh
uh series in a row
they're like seven games above 500.
we're on our way we're gonna clinch the
[__] wild card
probably draw the yankees and then all
the pressure's going to be on them
because they're going to win like 120
games
and what's crazy about the playoffs now
is you can come limping in
winning 89 90 games
get the [__] wild card and knock off
a team
you know okay if they get hot at the
right time i mean i'll tell you these
guys these guys could be dangerous
this is the 89 and [__] 91 team you
nobody wants to play
sorry i didn't have time to do the math
was it 162 games so that would be 89
just for the [__]
rain men out there 89 and 73.
i'll tell you right now this is this is
this is the 89 and 73 team nobody wants
to play
all right
they're a little banged up
you know but but somewhere somewhere in
august
somewhere in august these these guys
they were down eight games and they had
a meeting
a players-only meeting
i told the manager to go [__] himself
obviously what he was doing for the
first four months wasn't doing [__]
and uh you know hats off
to uh eddie herzog because he he let him
do it and uh you know that's the type of
thing as a manager i mean now also part
of managing is knowing when not to
manage
does that make sense no one ever says
does that make sense
you know it says does that make sense
dumb people
or maybe like non-confident people
e equals m c squared
does that make sense
[Music]
thank you that was my uh
uh unconfident albert einstein if he
[__] grew up in massachusetts
um
anyway
you know i follow a wide
variety of things
on social media and what i [__] hate
is you know you click on one [__]
thing and then that's all they show you
well not one you click on six of them
and then that's it
it's like this guy just likes this so
then you gotta [__]
like go the other
direction you know i was compared to
like netflix when i watched one season
of narcos and then everything i had was
behind the scenes san quentin how not to
get [__] in the ass and rhode island
penitentiary all of this [__] it's just
like dude do you think this is
this is all i am
watching this [__] i mean
you gotta throw in one punch man
which i have to get back to watching if
i ever get free time little japanese
anime you watch your western then you
watch narcos
and then you throw in one of those
lesbian or gay shows
and then you're like there you go there
you go netflix algorithm figure that one
out
and you know what you'd end up watching
what would you end up watching i'm
trying to think ah [__] i was trying to
think of a gay rock star that star
starred in a movie
hopefully the period piece
i don't know anyway
cruising through hollywood i don't know
where the [__] everybody is the last
couple of days
i know yesterday was was a was a
banker's holiday
is that what it was
i have no idea but whatever i found i
follow a wide variety of things and uh
i saw this [__]
horrible yet informative thing
all right get ready for your white guilt
it was talking about how
when slavery ended first of all they
didn't tell slaves in like texas or
something for two [__] years
you know no smartphones back then so
they continued to be slaves for two
years
and then
in order to get around the law that
there's no slave labor
they created all of these these laws
new laws that black people couldn't do
this and couldn't do that little
frivolous [__] with super high fines
and if they couldn't pay the fines they
had to go to jail
and work for free
prison labor
it's [__] brutal man
the more you see like read about that
type of [__] i know there's going to be
a couple of people out there you know
[__] you should read about that [__]
really makes you it puts a lot of stuff
now like into perspective you understand
it way more
other than you know
you know those [__] morons that post
on social media and they act like
history started today
and they don't look at like okay this
happened and then this happened then
this led to this
that's why i always defend the southern
man
the southern white male is the
responsibility
of the north
the way we treated them after we won the
war now granted they tried to break away
from us but we were [__] with them
and [__] with them anyway
and then once they broke away you know
and we beat them in the war we treated
them like [__] you know their school
system sucked
still to this day you know as a talk
show host you can [__] on southern
people and accents just make jokes about
them being inbred and [__] their own
sisters and nobody gives a [__]
and uh
you
know you treat people like [__] they're
gonna [__] behave a certain way so i
think it's high time northern whities
yankees like myself
you know
[__] ease up a little bit
i actually did some uh some press
and uh
one of the radio stations i was calling
into
i called in npr and i had a blast with
them and they were like giving me [__]
because i trashed npr i was like i like
npr and they go oh you took the bait and
then they played the clip and i go well
what do you guys think you're above
being trashed
and i go you guys look at like 40 of the
states in this country like their
flyover states and the guy goes they are
flyover states they go name one
and he goes alabama i go i love alabama
and he goes well that makes sense i go
what you listen to one [__] neil
young song i didn't say [__]
but uh
i had a really good time on that that
show but like
if i was a little more on my game what
the [__] are you doing buddy nobody can
drive out here i swear to god
they just can't [__] drive out here
my wife actually saw a horrific accident
um
on the highway today and this truck was
all twisted up and she saw some guy who
just had blood all over his face and she
goes you just i was just like how does
that happen it's like how does that
happen how does that not happen every
five [__] minutes out here
these people drive like [__] lunatics
on the highway
you know and so many people just have
these crazy horsepowered cars now and
they [__] sit there zipping in and
out of traffic they don't give a [__] if
you got a
a little [__] car wow that's not left
turn in the [__] right lane you
douche
and a half a mile an hour
does it that way you know why because he
wanted to make a right on the last two
turns and they couldn't do it because
they were blocked off so now they're
like in that like thinking thing like
what what so what do i do
nah so every move they make is like they
[__] just ate a pot cookie
oh jesus bill
but anyway yeah people drive like
[__]
lunatics like last night i came home we
had the second screening of the movie
and um
which went great by the way i'm very
excited about that and i will be showing
the trailer
um
hopefully
soon in front of my shows
and um anyway i'm driving back
from the screening i'm you know making
mental notes remembering what worked
what didn't
and i'm driving like 75 miles an hour
right
so i don't know what the speed limit is
out here 55 60. i'm like 15 miles over
the speed limit i got past
simultaneously on the left and the right
like i was [__] sitting still
so if you ever come out here
it's a great place i definitely love la
but like people drive like that [__]
idiot i was just talking about on
surface streets
everybody drives around like like they
they yeah like they're
they ate some weed and then when they
get out
on the highway they drive like absolute
[__] maniacs i think there's a thing
when like there's no traffic
like no one can believe it out here like
you just can't believe it so you're just
like [__] like let me just drive a
hundred miles an hour until this all
backs up again and i just don't think
that they think about what they're doing
uh how bad you can get [__] up how bad
you could [__] up somebody else bill is
this a podcast or is it like a public
service announcement i don't know
i don't know what it is that i do
anymore
i edit footage
um i'm actually on my way down to the
comedy store right now
to run my act you know so i'm not rusty
um
when i when i go up to go do portland i
got portland
i'm somewhere in washington
uh it's not seattle or tacoma i don't
really quite know where i'm gonna be i
think it begins with an a then i'm in
vancouver
and then i go over to calgary now
vancouver is like
you know very like
i don't know what very uh cosmopolitan
city calgary
they're a bunch of animals i mean they
they are like you know if you were going
to get into a fight you'd want to get
into a fight in vancouver you would not
want to get into a fight
in [__] calgary i mean
i mean i grew up in massachusetts with
maniacs i went to calgary i was like
these [__] people can drink
those [__] people
that whenever i think of doing stand-up
in calgary all i remember is just the
amount of times i heard an empty beer
bottle accidentally get kicked over
in whatever venue i was playing in it
had like no rug or anything and i just
kept hearing that
throughout the show and they were a
great crowd and all of that but god damn
it were they drunk
um that goes all the way back to when i
i did stand up uh i did this
amazing tour out there
with uh paul verzi i i i'd be afraid to
know how long ago that was it's probably
the better part of eight years ago
um
when we did that tour we started in
moncton worked our way east and then
came all the way across
and i think the last night we ended up
in cal because we did two shows in
calgary and then we went to vancouver
then they added another [__] show
back in calgary and that's where we
ended oh my god that's right
oh [__] and verzi
got like
he got extra [__] up that night
and uh
i had to stay up with him to make sure
that he was gonna make his car because i
had a later flight and i remember we got
to the uh
the la you know can you just tell your
friends kind of blacking out
you know
they just have like that [__] far
away look in their eye
like half a smile but all of a sudden
they look like they don't know how to
read
that was a look at on his face and we've
all been there i'm not judging the man
you know
just saying
so that should be a uh
it should be a uh it should be a good
time
um
what else what else i'll tell you what
else is i'm trying to make a right
[__] turn here
oh jesus christ there's always that one
douche just driving so [__] slow
that person just has all day
you know
why don't they understand
look at knocked wiped out a whole nother
block
just made a left on the sunset there's
this whole [__] air they wiped out
this whole [__] block and that's
where uh joni mitchell
was singing uh
don't know what you got till it's
gone and you know pave
uh paved paradise put up a parking lot
she sang about that because i guess
there was some beautiful house there
with these amazing like
you know
shrubs and greenery and all this type of
stuff and all the singer songwriters
that were broke living up in laurel
canyon
where um
you know used to always look at that
place saying man someday i'm gonna write
a hit i'm gonna live in a place like
that and then just one day they just
knocked the whole thing down
you know and built like this [__]
strip mall
and they just now they just knocked that
down and in that strip mall there was a
there was a chase
bank and there was a mcdonald's so you
would think right there there's no
[__] way
that's ever going out of business
and they must have offered them a whole
bunch of money
oh gee bill yeah yeah exactly what do
you think they just walked in there and
told me to get the [__] out of course
they offered him a bunch of money
um
all right i'm pulling into the store so
i'm going to uh do my spot
and i'll be back in a couple seconds and
i'll let you know how it went
um
man everything's dead what is going on
everything is [__] dead
the saddle ranch
who would have thought that that [__]
place would stick around that long
the hell is that
yeah that's what we need we need one
more [__] game show
um
all right and here we go we're pulling
into this oh this is exciting isn't it
huh
pulling in to the comedy store
everybody looking down
they got the tv on over there
all right here we go all right i'll let
you know how my set went
all right and just like that
just like that old freckles did a couple
of [__] spots one in the maid room
one in the original room
um
man i just had a [__] good time
i really did the first crowd made me
feel old i mean i am old
but i usually sort of connect with them
they were just staring at me like i was
i think they were just polite or they
were smart
sometimes when a crowd's quiet it isn't
necessarily that you're bombing
it's uh
it's that they're listening
you know i'm not gonna lie to you some
of the times it's it's because you suck
but i remember that remind me when i was
in finland they were just [__]
staring at me and i was like
oh jesus what the [__] am i doing here
i just got t-boned
um they were just staring at me
and i i couldn't understand like what
was going on i've told this story a
zillion times and then i finally
finished a joke
i'm like are you guys all right like
what's going on here and this guy was
just like well why didn't you justify
the devil i was just like oh my god
that's what they're doing they're trying
to figure out the problems of the jokes
um
but that wasn't they were just sort of
young and polite because anytime i would
be like
saying something to him whatever then i
went into the o.r
and i don't know why
i just went up there and started talking
about homeless people
no i know i was talking to a comic and
he was talking about california running
out of water
and all this gloom and doom [__] with
you know the typical [__] they bring up
all the gloom and doom they have no
solution
and you're like what the [__] right
thanks for dumping that on me
and i was thinking like you know last
night i was
i was driving uh
oh that's how i got into talking about
it because i was driving down the street
and uh there was just this fire
so i called 9-1-1
and then like 9-1-1 what's your
emergency i was like there's a fire i go
some homeless guy started a fire
and they go let me put you on with the
fire department and i just kept saying
some homeless guy started the fire and
you know i didn't see the homeless guy
start the fire
i didn't see him start the fire
but i [__] blamed that guy um anyway
um
so i just started riffing about that
[__] and everybody was staring at me
like i was an [__]
and uh
so i just went harder
and i kept a straight face as long as i
could i was saying that they should just
take all the homeless people and push
them into the la river
and wait for the rain season a week in
february and just wash them all out to
the ocean and uh
at that point it was like dead silent in
there and and i i couldn't hold it
together anymore and i laughed and then
they all laughed and realized that was a
[__] idiot
um
so
good time good time had by all at least
i like to think so there was one one
when the whole time i was up there
like this her screen was on and she was
like texting that's what i that happens
to me a lot
and i don't know if it's like some
passive aggressive way of of being like
i'm gonna show you how much i don't care
about what you're talking about i'm
gonna be on my fan
um
so what i do is i just i whatever the um
[__] like that happens i just start
sending my act in that direction
and i start acting even sillier
and having if i give a [__]
which i didn't tonight but like if the
person really seems like they're they're
trying
to annoy me
um
or they're not enjoying my act and i act
extra silly
i kind of use their negativity to sort
of propel it
you know
where as much as they're trying to annoy
me i'm annoying them
i used to do that when i was coming up
in the clubs that there'd be some stone
faced person in the front row
and you know i used to always take the
bait like sir what's the matter how are
we not laughing or lady what's the
problem i started to like
you know especially if they were down
front i would walk all the way up to the
edge of the stage and i would like sort
of swing my arm out and hopefully i'll
be like above their head
as i was like doing my accident at that
point they were like staring at my
[__] dick
except my crotch like right in their
[__] face and you'd only do it for a
second you know because you never know
they could punch you in the balls and
then you just go back down to the other
side or whatever
and it was funny you could actually turn
it around
um
at least that's that's how i remember it
i may be like one of like one of those
old athletes
who's now just talking about their glory
days throwing a bunch of [__] mustard
on it and [__] but anyways everybody
uh my order is in
oh billy freckles got is a ford f250
coming his way
i can't wait oh my god i gotta get nia
on the podcast she thinks it is the
stupidest
[__] thing
that i ever bought it's so funny she
just sits there
like i i'm such like i try to get her
excited about it it's been like we've
had so much fun
with it because
she's just like ah hey i mean you know
that's uh
that's what you want driving around a
big old truck or whatever she just
thinks it's dumb and i'm like come on i
got the bench seat you know
you can you know like you can sit right
next to me like old school style
like back in the day
she's just
she's i might as well be i don't know
what i i mean i would have a better
chance to take him to a football game
than getting her to [__] ride in that
truck she just doesn't give a [__]
she just thinks they're stupid like on
father's day i took her out my uh
my old f-100
i was like you know you wanted to you
know she always takes me out for a cigar
and uh i love going to cigar bars with
my wife because she's funny as hell
and uh the guys always end up liking her
because she can bust balls and all that
type of [__] she knows how to hang
basically
so we got this cigar bar that we always
go to
and uh
you know
sometimes we sit inside sometimes we sit
outside but we always end up meeting
like
interesting people or whatever
and um
so anyways i was saying hey you want to
ride in my old truck and she's just like
yeah yeah no
and i just laughed and she goes i know
it's father's day you want to drive it
all right let's take the truck right and
i go why don't you like the truck man
it's [__] cool
she goes yeah it's just so loud and
bumpy
so you know
what am i i mean what i'm going to lie
it's not going to lie it is it is loud
and it is bumpy but i like it
um
anyway
so
i got to do some advertising at some
point i'm just going to say i'm going to
do it here i don't have the advertising
as of yet
um what is it
how much time have i done here 23
minutes it's probably a couple two three
minutes of [__] i'm coming down to
the end here all right it's time for the
advertising and i was wrong i thought
the colorado was up three games to one
it was only two games to one
but now it's three games to one so i
feel like i predicted something
um
simply safe everybody
you know today's episode of the monday
morning podcast is brought to you by
simply safe home security i believe
i believe every home
should be the safest place on the earth
for every family that's why
i use and recommend simply safe
simply safe is advanced whole home
security that puts you your home and
your family's safety first here's why i
love it
it's adorable no simply safe offers
comprehensive protection not only
against intruders and burglary but
against expensive home hazards from
flooding to fires with 24 7 professional
monitoring simply safe agents take
action the moment a threat is detected
dispatching police or first responders
in an emergency even if you're not home
simply safe uses proprietary video
verification technology so that
monitoring agents can visually confirm
the threat in order to get
highly higher priority 911 dispatch
monitoring plans are affordable
affordably priced at a dollar a day
with no long-term contract or hidden
fees because feeling safe at home
shouldn't break the bank
you can customize the perfect system for
your home in just a few minutes at
simply safe.com
go today and claim a free indoor
security camera plus twenty percent off
with interactive monitoring go to
simplysafe.com s-i-m-p-l-i-s-a-f-e
dot com
okay look who it is everybody it's helix
sleep helix
helix sleep has a quiz that takes just
two minutes to complete and matches your
body type
your special body type and sleep
preferences
to the perfect mattress for you why
would you buy a mattress made from
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be perfect
for the way you sleep everybody's unique
and helix knows that so
why the helix haven't you gotten one yet
sorry so they they have several
different mattresses mattress models to
choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
mattress is great for spinal alignment
to prevent morning aches and pains and
even a helix plus mattress for plus size
sleepers all the big boys
where the hell did my copy just
go now dog got it i was moving along
just fine and all of a sudden it just
disappeared oh here we go
um so if you're looking for a mattress
you take the quiz you order the mattress
that you need
helix is awesome
but you don't need to take my word for
it helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress picks pick of 2020 by
gq magazine that's where all the
good-looking guys who know how to dress
stand around and let their picture be
taken and wired magazine for all you
cokeheads out there
what the hell ex has been recommended by
multiple leading chiropractors and
doctors of sleep
medicine
as a go-to solution for improving sleep
just go to helixsleep.com
take their two-minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life you're starting to
catch on here if not they're going to
repeat what i just said three more times
they have a 10-year warranty there's
some new information and you get to try
it out for a hundred night risk free
they'll pick it up for you gross
if you don't love it after a hundred
nights wow but you will helix even has
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com that's helix sleep.com
for 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows go guess who needs a mattress
all freckles i'm gonna have to get one
all right that's it and enjoy the rest
of the podcast
i'm coming down to the end yeah so right
now i'm trying to get the uh the movie
trailer together so when you guys come
out to the show
uh you can check out you know a quick
little 90-second thing
before i get uh before i get out there
and uh i will tell you guys this when i
get this movie done
i think it's gonna be great
it's it's
you know
it's the
tone of my act basically this movie in
that
um
i'm having people talk
the way i hear people talk or whatever
but anyway i'm gonna need
to rally the troops like when this thing
comes out
wherever it comes out and theater's
streaming or whatever i will i'm gonna
be calling in a favor
for you guys jesus christ with the
goddamn lamborghini there
you know i never used to like
lamborghinis i kind of like them now
you know i mean i would never get one
but i i like that somebody does
i kind of like that one it was like that
was like ford racing blue with the uh
with that orange
an orange stripe on it
so anyway um
yeah i'm gonna need uh i'm gonna need
you guys
to go out and and drag like four people
with you just so uh
you know i gotta make sure these people
get their money back
i can't have uh
too old for a flop people i'm not gonna
lie to you i'd be one and done that's it
it's like i came up to the pros at
[__] 30 years of age
he lit up one [__]
deep ball and that's it
um
hey man i've been playing some drums too
by the way and i gotta tell you my foot
is faster than it's ever been
uh
i just been doing this
this exercise
playing just all triplets
between the hands and the feet and that
type of [__]
and uh like i don't know like five or
six different licks
one of which being right kick kick you
know just going around the drums and all
of that [__] and i think just
doing that every day has just really
been uh beneficial for me and going in
and out of each one
sort of trying to flow around the drums
like all of my favorite drummers are
able to do
but uh i also started doing it with my
left foot
um and you know my left foot was like
it's like it belonged to somebody else
you know what i mean like that's how bad
the thing was
and uh
i never really developed it and now
it's actually like sort of intermediate
fast
and i was playing along with some uh
panda pantera the other day you know
that cowboys from hell the end the
double bass part
there's like three hits
to the snare you know the bat did it
about and uh i i lead with my left foot
for whatever reason on that so it's two
kicks and i slip one right in the middle
of it
and it was the tightest and cleanest
i've played it so of course now i'm
going on the [__] road
um
so i might lose a few bpms but i sat
down i played with uh
traveling riverside blues which is at 90
bpms and i played along with good times
bad times and i was able to get through
most of it
um i kind of feel like i'm right there
so i'm just going to keep pushing
through with this uh
so whatever i'm a [__] eight-year-old
everybody buying a [__]
giant tonka truck for myself and i'm
still playing drums what are you gonna
do and i'm telling [__] jokes in
portland the state of washington
somewhere
vancouver and calgary i'm gonna have a
great time i am bringing uh
joe bartnick and nate craig with me
we're gonna have an absolute [__]
blast and i'm really
psyched
that the tampa bay lightning
came back
and won one game to give us another game
of hockey here at least
and uh so i can watch with those um
those two lunatics it's gonna be a good
time so that's it everybody enjoy the
music
um
picked out by andrew themless the great
andrew themless and then we'll have a
bonus half hour special thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast thank you guys for
listening and i hope the car wasn't too
loud here but uh that's it have a great
weekend your cards
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
june 23rd
how's it going how are you what's up and
all of that [__]
um
i don't know where do i start
i don't even know where to begin
i take my special friday night in
atlanta at the tabernacle and i want to
thank everybody who came out
i had a wonderful time as always there
were a couple of glitches as always a
couple people screamed out and as always
what the [__] are you gonna do i had a
great time
and um
i'm really looking forward to putting
that special out and uh coming up with
my new hour of material and right now
i'm trying not to freak out because
essentially
when this thing comes out in a couple
months i have no i mean i have an act
but it will be an act that potentially
people in the crowd have seen
so
i have to try some uh i don't know what
the [__] i'm going to do
you know you know what i do when i try
to build the new hour no bill we don't
know nor do we give a [__] well [__] you
it's my podcast i'm gonna talk about it
um what i like to do basically i i
basically i take off all rules
of like hackneyed [__] i don't give a
[__] i will i will talk about anything
so i am now
i'm just looking what's go what's what's
going on in the news
hey it's a little interesting thing here
yeah it's like jay leno's bit right
where he takes like the uh
the headlines
except he actually has a staff of
writers combing through
to actually find funny ones i on the
other hand will be going down to the
clubs just throwing anything i can up
against the wall why the [__] is it so
hot in here
jesus christ and i can't open the
[__] windows
because my neighbors are gonna freak out
i'm taping this sunday night so
everybody's home right now
god damn it
ah jesus that's not one [__] thing
it's not you know what i was going to do
it in the bedroom
you know but my wife wants to go take a
bath and relax
which you know
is that wrong no it's not wrong
you know is it is it is it pathetic that
i can't do a podcast in the in the next
room without disturbing her because i
scream and yell and rant and rave and
all that [__] that's pathetic i guess
that is pathetic so i am i'm out here in
the living room
and i can't open the [__] windows and
i tell you the heat's getting to me
already
oh it's getting to me um
what would you rather do would you
rather freeze to death i'll give myself
a dilemma here would you rather freeze
to death or uh
i'm not gonna say burned to death
everybody's gonna choose
freezing to death although there'll be a
couple of douches well both of them are
going to be painful so i'd rather get
the pain over with
you know hit me with some sort of
scientific facts
or whatever he'll just say some science
[__] they don't even have to be facts
when it comes to my scientific
background of which i have none
you know i took two goddamn classes
no i didn't even do that
one was chemistry and i was just like
i'm not [__] looking at bugs
you know
i know it's not bugs but i had to follow
through with that sentence because
that's the first thing i thought of when
i was looking
looking in the petri dish
what are you looking at huh oh that's
biology so i was still wrong
chemistry
you know what i love about this [__]
podcast is how dumb you guys think i am
not how dumb you think i am but like how
much smarter like the [__] that you guys
write i swear to god
you're you're [__] animals just like
me
all right but whatever maybe that's my
job my job's to make you feel better
better
i don't know
i have no idea
um
but anyways yeah my science my science
background's horrific
i took uh
i just didn't give a [__] when i was
younger they shouldn't try to teach you
that [__] when you're young
you know you're too busy staring at the
[__] hot chicks in class
you're sitting there with a [__] rod
you know trying to memorize a periodical
chart you can't do that and if you can
you know what i don't even know what the
[__] you are you're not even a human
being how are you not looking at the
chick that developed the quickest
you know
with the tits over there or jordas jeans
whatever sass on whatever the [__] they
had back when i was a kid
that's what you're looking at or even
worse you had some hottie for a [__]
teacher that you wanted to bang
you know let me tell you about that time
i got trouble i got in trouble a long
time ago i was taking this french class
[Music]
and the teacher i had was beautiful
and she had a habit of wearing dresses
where she had a slit halfway up the side
of her [__] leg
you know i'm in the eighth grade what am
i supposed to do well long story short
one day she came in she had a slit up
bolt on both sides of the dress
right so she would be writing on the
board and when she would step back
did i ever tell her so i came out she
would step back so you could see
you know
she'd step one leg back
and then somehow you could basically see
halfway up her leg
on her inner thigh
on the leg closest to the blackboard and
like the [__] it was over
all right no blood in my brain i'm just
going all i'm
doing is thinking how to say in french
please step back again
see who play i have no idea i don't i'm
not even [__] listening and to this
day i don't know i never i was one of
the worst i ever had a teacher yell at
me she called on me
all right and i'm trying to [__]
answer her
and i'm trying to [__] my way
through and she realizes that i i
haven't been [__] paying attention
and she flipped out calling me a liar
and screen to this day i swear to god
something was going on in her home life
because it's like yeah i mean you should
just called me a [__] liar and
moved on
she just [__] she berated me for like
the last 20 minutes of the class
um
i remember jesus i'm rubbing my head now
thinking about i was just sitting there
you know
you know how many times i've thought
about that [__] moment in my life and
i just wish that i had the emotional
maturity to be like you know you weren't
paying attention were you i'd be like no
i wasn't
i wasn't why don't you you know not come
to class
all right with two slits on both sides
you dress and i won't be you know what
your inner thigh is way more interesting
than watching you uh go
sweet to a and all of that [__] crap
okay send me down to the office what do
you want
what do you want from me i don't give a
f yeah whatever i'm not passing this
class anyways am i
am i i you know what [__] this i want to
thank you for dressing the way that you
do because that [__] you're writing on
the board is not interesting it's not
nearly as interesting
as what's going on downstairs there okay
and quit acting like you don't know what
you're doing and you're yelling at me
you're getting on me you're having a bad
time with your [__] husband that's
what it is what's the matter he doesn't
want to touch you anymore so now you got
to come in here all gussied up get us
all hot and bothered
right
and then [__] scream and yell at me
because i'm not paying you you're not
you're not even yelling at me you're
yelling at your [__] husband can you
imagine actually i probably wouldn't got
half that out
i don't [__] know you know not to
mention i had you know i guess i had
really bad add
i can't you know the only time i can
focus is if i give a [__] about
something or my life is in jeopardy
you know like i went on a motorcycle
ride today with a buddy of mine and we
drove all the way down sunset all the
way down and all the way back
and i gotta tell you uh
i don't see the enjoyment in riding a
motorcycle i don't get it
it it always looks awesome but once
you're on there all you're thinking is
i'm gonna die
that's a [__] range rover jesus
christ get the [__] away from me
you know
the whole [__] you can't look at
anything all you're doing is making you
driving down the street you're making
sure that nobody's pulling out somewhere
no one's gonna open a door up you get up
to a [__] stop light you gotta look
in your rearview mirror to make sure
nobody rear-ends you and pushes you out
into traffic
it's [__] horrific you're going
around a turn you to look your way
through the god damn term and then make
sure the other [__] across the street
you know coming the other way isn't
going to wipe you out
but i got to tell you my focus is
incredible
[Laughter]
i guess that's the only way i can focus
or if there's like something something
is on uh
on the line other than that i just
started staring at bugs on the ceiling
or whatever i don't know what it is i do
i'm out of my [__] mind
so anyways uh
what was i talking about oh yeah so i
take my special this weekend and um
you know that's the fun part the
horrific part now is i have to go back
and i got to uh
go in during the editing process and
that's not something i like doing i got
this weird thing if i videotape myself
for the club i can sit there and i can
watch it and i can laugh and i can enjoy
it but the second i know you guys are
going to see it too i get all in my head
and everything i'm doing i think ah jay
why did i do that what am i doing blah
blah why did i say this
you know
why is my weight on my right leg right
now instead of my left leg it's [__]
torture so i got to push my way through
it because uh
you know
i um trying to make sure you know with
each special you know you want to be a
little bit better than you were the last
time you want to look a little bit
better than the last one
so uh i didn't realize with that also
become comes the pressure of of uh
i don't know
trying to trying to keep going up
i don't [__] know i don't know
whatever it's behind me okay so now
basically what i'm doing is i'm looking
over these uh
i'm trying to watch the news which i
can't do
because i don't know about i don't know
where you guys live in the world but we
don't really have news
over here we have a little bit of it but
for the most part it's basically uh the
democrat news and the republican news
it's really [__] sad
um
i used i like the way they used to lie
to us
i liked it back in the day you know when
they just had that person
that [__] older white guy
who who had that sound in his voice
that just sounded like he [__] you
know was giving you the straight deal
you know
as opposed to now we got all these
personalities
that are like bigger than the news
you know all those silly [__] on fox
news and all those [__] on cnn
who's that guy with the [__] silver
hair
on cnn what is he what does he call his
show
ah jesus christ i
i can't remember you got though you got
the one calls at the the situation room
which remember opie and opie and anthony
used to always make fun of the situation
room
and you got what's his face going yeah
this is a no spin zone that bill
o'reilly jerk off this is a no spin zone
it's like dude the your your entire
[__] show was you spinning it
there's no such thing
there's no spin zone right now i'm
spinning
how i think news is in this country so
you guys agree with what the [__] i say
there's no such thing
like i'm gonna give you the straight
dirt even if you wanted to you couldn't
because you're getting it off that
[__]
whatever the [__] it is that ticker tape
thing that you get it you weren't there
you don't know what happened and even if
you were there i'm gonna get it it's
gonna be what happened cut with your
childhood that's what's going to happen
because it goes into your brain and then
it's [__] in there and it's stepped
on like drugs it's not the pure [__]
that just happened so i can't watch it
what the [__] does that guy call this
show
that silver-haired guy
it's something arrogant something
arrogant like he's giving you you know
what the [__] is supposed to be
happening anderson cooper
360. is that what it is i thought it was
worse than that 360 is not bad right
he's spinning around as he tells the
news
today in egypt
uh sorry terrible joke anders but you
know what i'll put that in my act i need
jokes anderson cooper 36 look at that
net worth who the [__] would look up his
well now it's just guys making a year
what did they do they said did he read
teleprompters ah i could do that
i thought he had something i thought it
was called something worse than that
anderson cooper 360.
sounds like one of them uh x game tricks
you did a backside fakie followed by
anderson cooper 360.
jesus christ insert homophobic joke
there like what would what would an
anderson cooper 360
skateboard look like
oh
that's you know what that's too easy
full coverage
from anderson live in baghdad i gotta
tell i know what annoys me is when he
goes out and he tells a story he's got a
[__] helmet on
you know what i mean
jesus chris a helmet won't even help you
on a motorcycle okay you're out you're
in a [__] war zone
take it off and show your great hair you
son of a [__]
anderson cooper 360 spinning around live
here in baghdad
republicans do everything wrong
um
oh keeping them honest
is that's is that what is that what he
does
why am i asking you guys why didn't i do
my [__] research on this thing
keeping them honest gay
conversion therapy
oh jesus christ i can't imagine the
tension there dude how [__] [__]
are you that you actually think that you
can stop somebody
from
being attracted to what they're
attracted to and then also thinking that
it's unnatural
you know
i don't understand that
uh unless you're talking about
pedophiles but even them it's the way
they're wired as something happened to
them and then they try to undo that
wiring that's noble work but i mean at
the end of the day i mean we all know
what needs to happen
you got to take them out behind the barn
and give them the old [__] old yeller
treatment right it's over
you can't help it i know it's not your
fault you want to have you want to [__]
a kid
we can't have that
okay
maybe someday in the future i don't know
when but not now
when would you i don't know when you
would but it's it's
it's not gonna happen so you're done
it's over
quit your crying
be a goddamn man right and then that's
it
so
keeping them honest gay conversion
therapy look at this [__] weirdo
how do they try to convert you from not
being gay i bet they just have you
sitting there right if it's a gay a gay
man and they'd be like all right
okay we're gonna do something different
here okay what i want you to do is uh
think about having sex with a man okay
are you doing it yeah yeah i'm doing it
all right just keep thinking about that
you're having sex you know
he smells like old spice you know
whatever you're into blah blah blah and
it gets the [__] dude aroused and
then he just has some naked woman come
in and do like a flying scissor kick and
put her snatch right in his face right
gets that stinker on him while he still
has an erection
thinking that maybe that would take
you know other than that i don't know
how you do it
[Music]
but what's funny about that was then if
they wanted to convert me to being gay
that they would do the exact same thing
except the flying
scissor kick would be somebody's package
coming flying at my face i mean
i'm gonna go on a limb and say that
that's not gonna work
dude how isolated are you as a [__]
human being that you're actually part of
a group that's trying to do some [__]
like this
i mean i guess people looked at orville
and wilbur wright like are you out of
your [__] mind
you're trying to fly
that's crazy so maybe they think that
they're doing that except with like
sexuality
you know what's funny about the early
planes
is when the people didn't understand
that the flapping of the wings was to
gain speed
so they tried to have like the like well
like i don't know isn't that what they
thought
isn't that something else that i haven't
read about they thought that
it's got something to do with the
flapping of the wings
before they realize like no we we just
need to somehow gain some speed we got
to build something that somebody can run
with
oh jesus i look [__] you guys i already
told you i didn't take any science
classes okay cause you know anyways
jesus this [__] podcast is all over
the place uh
let's let's do a little advertising here
all right um
convert your kid back to being straight
kit
no kidding all right uh
dollar shave club everybody
the big razer companies think we're
stupid
every year they roll out some ridiculous
shave technology gimmick and expect us
to shell out big bucks for it yeah they
got that new uh that ball thing oh they
got it there vibrating handle roller
pivot ball
back scratcher egg timer laser pointer
corkscrew all of that crap
um
do we really need that people
personally i know that i don't
i know that i don't i know that i was
fine with two [__] blades one sucked
unless you had a straight blade stra
what do you call a straight razor
or if you had one of those uh what do
they call those safety razors
those things are fine but if you're just
talking about a gillette style razor
which is what these people are selling
okay
all you need is the two [__] blades
personally that's what i'm thinking
anyways he said we were shaving just
fine before any of that junk and i
definitely don't need to spend my hard
earned cash on it if you're sick of
being treated like a fool join the
hundreds of thousands of smarter people
who join dollarshaveclub.com
dollar shave club delivers the best
blades and grooming supplies for just a
few bucks a month even if this [__] was
the same
the fact that they're gonna bring it to
your door this is a no-brainer their
blades are better than the big shave
companies for a fraction of the price
all right
my listeners can get started now at
dollarshaveclub.com and hey if you're
already a member you got to check out
their new doctor carvey's post shave
lotion
it's the perfect way to make peace with
your face after the disruptive act of
shaving and you know something nobody
ever teaches us how to shave
okay nobody ever tells you about putting
something on your face before you lather
it up you just drag that razor across
and nobody ever talks about any sort of
uh aftershave so good for dr cobby uh
anyway stop getting ripped off uh by the
big shave companies join
dollarshaveclub.com that's
dollarshaveclub.com
all right another one here legalzoom
everybody america was built by
innovators and dreamers people like
thomas edison and henry ford laid the
foundation for our country after they
removed
well after the native americans were
removed who were kind of living off the
land and uh
i got him it looked pretty good
anyways these days it's the adventures
and entrepreneurs entrepreneurs all
around us like you that keep our country
running by fueling the job market and e
and the economy this month legalzoom
celebrates innovation by helping you
launch your dream apply for a patent to
secure your invention basically
everybody they're gonna help you they
can't help you with your invention but
what they can do is give you a foot to
stand on when some fat cat comes in and
tries to steal it from you okay
register your trademark to protect your
products and services incorporate or
form an llc and launch your business the
right way visit legalzoom.com and use
the discount code bur b-u-r-r they'll
provide the
the personal attention you need and help
take care of all the details they've
helped over a million businesses get
started right and they received an a
plus from the better business bureau
celebrate innovation and legalzoom
today and get a special price on
trademark copyright or provincial patent
of applications by using the discount
code burr at the checkout legalzoom
provides legal help through independent
attorneys and self-help but they are not
a law firm legalzoom.com discount code
burr b-u-r-r
alrighty back to the
podcast um
all right so what am i going to talk
about now oh so today
so i came back uh
oh by the way you know it was awesome
after i after i did the taping at the
beautiful tabernacle tavern tabernacle
theater
in atlanta um
[Music]
jason lawhead
he uh
was looking for a place we could go out
and smoke some cigars
and it turned out right in part of the
same building part of the tabernacle is
a new cigar place called uh
winston's cigars
and uh i went in there and had a great
cigar they kept the place open late for
us i want to thank everybody over there
for uh
for letting us hang around and all of
that shite we had a great time and uh
definitely gonna stop there again next
time i come back and if you live in
atlanta and you like cigars you want a
cool place to hang out to put on any
kind of music you want
to put the game on for you it was
absolutely perfect got to hang out with
a couple in there from worcester
so uh it was it was a great time it's
definitely a great time so
anyways um
so now that i'm back here in town
uh you know i stayed up till like five
in the morning did not drink though
did not drink i am i am i'm saving
myself for those you listen to my
podcast every week you know that uh ever
since i came back from france i have not
drank
i am up to i don't know how many [__]
days by the time you listen to this i'll
be on my 67th day
and uh i'm going to vegas and i'm going
i decided i'm going off the wagon in
vegas i got two shows
uh friday and saturday night in at the
mirage casino
and it just so happens that the tour
that the monday morning podcast has been
sponsoring the tour that has been
crushing it in the clubs all around the
country
the tour
that includes
paul dude i called it verzi
joe bartnick
rose bowl tailgate legend and uh rose
boat tailgate legend and grill cook
extraordinaire jason lawhead
will be at harrah's at the improv
uh this sunday i'm at the mirage friday
saturday and then my buddies are there
sunday so what am i going to do not hang
out of course i'm going to hang out
i'm going to go and i'm going to check
out their show
over at harrah's and you know what so
should you
it'll be a great time
fun for all
fun for all and who knows maybe even a
couple of special guests
when we're in vegas you never know who
drops in
um
so
so anyways i haven't been drinking so
today uh i was like all right you know
i've been on the road and [__] getting
ready for this uh taping i'm gonna take
my wife out she wanted to go to the
beach right so i got my little
motorcycle ride in in the morning i
didn't die
and uh
came back and i took her out to the
beach and
i went over to uh
oh i did my workout over there
right over there on muscle beach i stood
there in a little banana hammock showing
off my [__] pasty body now they got
uh they got pull-up bars and they got
rings and they got the rope
over there i hate the [__] new rope
now
they they used to have like a real rope
now this one's made like i don't know if
they put some protective thing on it
felt like it was almost made out of
plastic
um
i guess for the weather or something
like that so it wouldn't disintegrate
like the last one did but i did all
right
i did all right on it man i was able to
go almost all the way up to the top
without using my legs there and i got to
tell you for 46 that ain't bad that
ain't [__] bad so after that we drive
up to malibu and i'm thinking malibu
this is [__] you know all these rich
people are and everything this is going
to be nice we go to the beach and i tell
you i can't even begin
to describe the [__] animals
the absolute [__] animals
that were at the beach
i mean it is [__] horrific
f do you know what's [__] hilarious
is seeing people from my generation and
the generation before like the tattoos
that were in
you know
like did i saw this guy in the beach
right and now that everybody's older and
out of shape and has kids and [__] this
guy you know those [__] stars that
everybody had everybody got him in the
early 2000s they were like red
and then they had like some sort of
darker shading in him i mean i have a
friend that has two of them
i think one on each elbow so there's
some [__] guy roughly the same age as
my buddy he's got one just to the inside
of both shoulders which was sort of a
weird place for him but if he had more
tattoos it looked fine but he had no
other tattoos in that area
it was just weird
it's like what are you like a general in
your own life why why do you have those
[__]
stars there right so he's sitting there
you could tell he used to be in shape
you know
he used to have the pecs but now they're
kind of looking down staring at the
floor
big stupid pot belly and he's sitting
there as his kids are running around and
he's eating he's digging into this bag
of chips and they're not chips you know
those things that look like the onion
rings but they're not onion rings it's
like if you had a potato chip but it was
a [__]
shaped like an onion ring that he's just
sitting there eating those things
so this other dude come by
i know dude i i am obsessed with trying
to stay in shape and not become what i
see
okay at the [__] beach this guy comes
by latino guy right
[__]
big giant belly and tattooed on his
stomach you know like tupac had thug
life
this guy for some reason had pasadena
[Laughter]
oh it was awful
it was [__] awful there were two
hotties on the beach other than my wife
um
there was like the [__] model couple
guy and woman in front of us who looked
like they were they were shooting a
[__] uh guess ad and then all the way
down the way there was some chicken a
[__] pink bikini who was working out
on the beach total like exhibitionists
it was great
it was great i kept saying ania going
look what she's doing now look what
she's doing now
she's doing she's doing uh
leg lifts with the weights on her ankles
and she kept looking over going like oh
god
no i love when women get mad at other
women who are [__] prancing around
showing that clam
it's [__] hilarious
you know i'm trying to think of the guy
version of that
what would a guy be doing i guess i'm
trying to think of something that a guy
would be doing in that version that
would in that same scenario that
wouldn't make me laugh my ass off
do you think guys would do that would
ever bug me is uh
i guess walk up and just start you know
hitting on your girlfriend or your wife
or whatever right in front of i guess
that would be the only thing other than
that if they're walking around
peacocking i don't give a [__] i think
it's hilarious
you know and plus you're young go ahead
exactly
go [__] her in the surf while you still
can
so anyways we're sitting there
oh and the families
dude what kind of people go to the beach
as you can tell i'm not a beach person
so i never went
just [__] animals these [__]
people brought a table down they got a
large cheese pizza they're just sitting
on the beach getting fatter
you know it's like you're gonna take
your shirt off in a second you're gonna
slam you're gonna [__] down four
slices
a pepperoni mushroom
jesus christ
you know and i would love to see i don't
know i would love to act like you know
people try to act like it it's only in
america where everybody's all fat uh i
we are we are pretty goddamn fat
because our food is such [__] poison
um
but it's it's still a [__] show
everywhere else
i don't know in its own way oh speaking
of that do you know what's i was uh
i was in utah last week and i took this
picture and i put it up on twitter
and i was in the gym right the hotel gym
and they had a couple of ellipticals and
then they had a big window where you
looked outside right across the street
was uh this fast food place
so i took a picture of it just hashtag
like come on man you know like i'm
trying to lose weight here and you're
tempting me with this [__] so the fast
food place saw it
and then tried to write a joke about it
like trying to draw me into the
horseshit the [__] poison that
they're serving
hey we said why don't you come over here
afterwards and do some [__]
hamburger curls
get it that's what they hashtag you get
it you know acting like they're the cool
[__]
dealer of poison right and i just wrote
them back i was like no i don't get it
why would i work out and then go over to
your restaurant and eat that poison
kind of defeats the purpose of working
out no
and they never wrote back
stop acting like you're cool
you know what would be cool if they just
came out and said listen
what we're serving you is absolutely
[__] horrific
there's barely an ounce of nutrition in
this [__] but god damn it it is [__]
delicious so don't have it all the time
just every once in a while if they just
came out and said that
you know
i don't [__] know i don't know what
i'm talking about here i'm just trying
you know i'm just trying to get to
another podcast that's all i'm trying to
do um you know i really thought i was
going to have a big feeling of relief
when i finished my my special i could
get on with my life here and uh
kind of feel uh
i feel a little melancholy i'm really
going to miss those jokes i really am
man i [__] i i that was my favorite
hour and a half of [__] i've ever
written
and uh i don't know i might have to pull
out those a couple of those
every once in a while
somebody requests one or something
i might have to do that
i got this helicopter joke man wait wait
dc it's one of my favorite jokes i've
ever gotten it's just so much fun to
[__] do it you know it's that steve
jobs bit that i did i did that one on
night of too many stars that was a that
was a sad one to let go
i just loved when i was walking around
acting like he was eating a pear that
was so much [__] fun
just acting like an arrogant ass
trashing somebody that's accomplished
way more than i'll i'll ever accomplish
you know those are the funnest moments
in uh
in stand-up
is when you get to do [__] like that
just act like a [__] idiot and people
actually laugh and that's ah god damn it
making fun of oprah's fun
how was it how is it not fun to make fun
of somebody as successful as her who has
like 50 [__] houses in her own tv
network it's just fun do you guys know i
i one time i had a meeting right
and uh
i was meeting with the casting director
of uh of uh what is it
dreamworks
right and i know this sounds like a big
deal but this [__] happens all the time
all the time when you're out here from
the day you get out here you get a
meeting with like [__]
back in the day like castle rock was
doing all the sitcoms oh my god i got a
meeting with catherock
they have like nine sitcoms on and they
just meet with you and you think you're
going to get on a sitcom and you're
lucky if you get an audition within the
year they're just always meeting new
people right so this is all it's a it's
just a meeting right so i go over there
and i'm sitting in the waiting room
waiting to meet uh with this big time
casting director right
and
all of a sudden i hear uh
this woman sing
and goes i hear this woman sing go and
spielberg
like that
and i'm thinking like holy [__]
am i gonna see steven spielberg he's
he's at the top of this [__] chain
but you never see the top guy so i'm
like rubbernecking and all this [__] and
i look
and he's not there
but
the person who sang that it was oprah
winfrey
and she walked by and i'm sitting on the
couch going oh my god
i have made fun of you on like 50
[__] podcasts that she walked by with
her entourage
and uh for half a second we both i was
looking at her she actually looked over
at me and she just kept going
for half a second i was so arrogant i
thought she was gonna stop
and be like you're that punk ass who did
that [__] bit about me you know it
was gonna start yelling at me and she
didn't she just looked at me
like i was a lamp and she just kept
walking and i was like oh yeah that's
right she has other things to do
evidently she was just saying goodbye to
steven spielberg
[Laughter]
how funny is it that she doesn't just do
that on her show that she actually
really sings
stuff that she's saying
in real life did you ever see that
hilarious impression that maya rudolph
used to do
of oprah
she used to do that thing where she
would sing
to like the crowd
okay and everybody gets a new car
would do like that thing that she
actually does that in real life you know
isn't that nice there's a little
hollywood story for you people i dropped
two names in there without you even
noticing
um all right i don't know what to talk
about because
hockey's over basketball's over i'm
trying to get into baseball oh i will
tell you this
i'm actually thinking about getting the
baseball package and um as a red sox fan
you know what i really miss doing
watching yankee games
believe it or not
i absolutely love
watching the yankee telecast
more so than i like watching the red sox
one i don't even know why i think
because i lived in new york for so long
and i would just watch this but this is
when like i lived during the height of
the curse of curse of the babe when i
was there
so i [__] hated the yankees so i went
to yankee stadium a zillion times i
watched all of their [__] games just
sitting there rooting against him
i must have saw clemens pitch like 50
[__] times
i saw all of them i saw the 98 yankees
which is legendary now i mean i don't
think there's been a team like that
since
um
but
i got to be honest i don't know there's
something about it like i did it for so
[__] long i think i've actually
watched wired a wire more yankee regular
season games than i have red sox games
because i mean i was in new york for
like
i don't know like 12 years
and you know when i was a kid
growing up i mean the first 10 years of
your life i mean you just run around
throwing sticks and mud and [__] you're
not really paying attention
and then from
10 to 20
i don't know
i would watch them but you know you're
getting drunk for the first time you're
trying to get up some girl's shirt
you're busy
so then i just basically had from like
20 to 27 and then i moved
um
but i stayed in new york for like you
know [__] 12 years so i uh but i got
to tell you i love watching them now
because
they're they're announcing
team is it's the [__]
all right it's michael k
he's staring the ship and then i love
when there's nothing better when you
have former players
that are actually really good
broadcasters and they have paul o'neill
the former yankee great
and they have al leiter so you have one
one of the great hitters of the last 20
years and champions and then you have al
leiter
a pitcher so you got a picture and a
hair and just
the combination of the two of them man
it's just
a lighter is hilarious
[__] hilarious
and i and this is the thing i always
loved paul o'neill
and uh everybody in my family actually
[__] loved the guy because he was so
hilarious to us because we all have
tempers
and the funniest thing about paul and
neal was the amount of times i saw that
guy
come up to bat
hit a fly ball to right field the second
he hits it you'd see him put his head
down and go [__] and throw the bat down
and it would be a home run
into like the third row
like he
he was such a perfectionist
like the fact that he didn't get all of
it he was mad i guess what that you
didn't drive it 30 rows in and then in
every [__] time whether he got a hit
or whether he didn't get a hit
when he ran out to the field and he
would go out to right field he would
immediately
well i guess he'd throw the ball around
but once that was over he would be out
there in between like batters in between
pitchers and [__] he'd be out there
practicing his swing
i don't know there's just certain guys
even though they play on the team that
you hate you can't [__] hate the guy
the guy was great so i was watching one
of their telecasts recently and um
they actually
they cut to some footage of al leiter
facing paul o'neill and it was hilarious
and uh of course paul o'neill gets a hit
and then the last two that they showed
al leiter struck him out and he's like
oh i struck you out i didn't even know
that and then he looked over at michael
and he goes yeah and paul didn't get
that mad
that's [__] great
so i'm actually thinking about getting
the uh
the baseball package because i actually
have a package where i get the neson
network and i get the yes network
thinking that i get the [__] games
and i don't
they block the whole thing out because
they force you to buy you know so i get
the milwaukee brewer home games they're
such [__]
they're such [__] [__]
why can't they just you know
you know i guess it's my fault for
moving away
do you understand what i'm really
bitching about here that basically for
100 something bucks that now boohoo now
i have to watch all the baseball games
you want to strike all of that
god bless whoever came up with that
package um
uh
where am i going here all right world
cup soccer
have you guys been watching i hate to
say this man i haven't watched one
second of it and i actually for as much
as i make fun of uh
football
the real football uh i
you know i i totally respect it i think
it's a beautiful game i just wish i had
and i'm driving by the bars and i'm
seeing all the flags out and hearing
people screaming and yelling i wish i
had the time to watch it i know that
there's some games tomorrow i think
brazil will play somebody i'm actually
going to try
at least maybe to tape a game i got to
get into this [__] once every four years
the whole [__] world's going nuts
uh but hey
you know what i said that the united
states is gonna win it i said the fix is
[__] in and we are 101.
i haven't watched a second of it
i know that we tied portugal today which
to me seems pathetic
all right
portugal's barely in europe
it's like spain felt bad for him like
all right here's a little landing strip
you guys can [__] live over here okay
you can have your little football team
once every four years we'll let you run
around and sing your songs and wear your
scarves but other than that you pike the
[__] down
all right now for all you portuguese
people who are going to get mad at me um
write all the mean [__] you want and
then also tell me where i can do a show
in your country and i'll [__] do it
all right you guys can go there and you
can [__] heckle me by singing your
soccer songs or football songs
right in the middle of it and i'll give
you [__] and in the end
you know we'll trade jerseys you'll give
me your soccer jersey and i'll take off
one of my button downs
what the [__] was with that guy who
scored the gold today and he started
sucking his thumb
can anybody explain that to me
i don't understand
soccer every time you start to love it
somebody does some [__] like that and
then you just you just gotta walk away
so anyways we are 101
so we're gonna play germany next and
basically if we tie
if us and germany tie uh we move we
automatically advance
we're 101 germany's 101 and then
portugal and and ghana i think is in our
in our uh whatever division whatever the
[__] you call it quadrant
they they both i have yet to win a
[__] game so um
i don't know i i'm
i want us to win the world cup so bad
just because i love what i was talking
about last week just how much the world
would [__] hate us but i got to tell
you man i think we're going to win one
eventually we are going to win one and i
don't mean that like well [__] you know
they're going to play it every four
years forever
eventually everybody's gonna win one i
mean i think
we're on our way to winning one
as in i think we'll win one by twenty
thirty
all right which is saying something
considering how far behind we were and
in 2030 if you want to know i will be 62
years old
that's how fast it goes
you know jesus
and i'll be working on another [__]
special um
hopefully maybe it'll be my year off all
right let's plow ahead here um
[Music]
anything else here did the all-in tour
oh youtube [__] video of the week
i was watching this uh the dead weather
concert
i don't know how to prime p-r-i-v-e i
started watching this thing i was trying
to
i don't know what the [__] i was doing
i was doing something all of a sudden i
just started watching jack white videos
and i got to this i can't believe i
didn't see the dead weather live
because i got to tell you the lead
singer of that or at least what i've
been watching
that woman i hope i say her name right
allison
moss heart
uh is a [__] rock star i'm gonna go
see that band what is it the kill that
she's in
very rarely do you see a legitimate
[__] rock star and she's definitely
one
without a doubt so that's one of the
youtube videos of the week just [__]
watch it and what's cool also is jack
white's setup
uh his drum set up how he has everything
all level kind of like the way buddy
rich did but his is uh oh no actually
buddy rich's symbols were level that's
right this is some drum geek [__] you
can fast forward to this
but he has like it looks like he has a
rack tom
and then two different snare drums
all at the exact same level all at the
same level that you would have your
snare drum
um and then on the uh
to his right side he's got three floor
toms
the way tony williams used to have him
right you guys all know that right when
he had that yellow yellow kit do you
know i saw him at the regatta bar i saw
tony williams
and i knew he was awesome but i of
course didn't understand everything he
was doing and in between the break i
walked right up and stood next to his
drums
that classic yellow kit i saw him i saw
louis belson
shook his hand
and i saw uh roy haynes
i saw all these great jazz drums and of
course tony williams like died a couple
years later unfortunately from a heart
attack but uh
anyways what the [__] why am i talking
to you guys about old jazz drummers
jesus christ
uh let's let's get to some questions
here
um oh by the way too if you want to if
you want to um
send in some questions or whatever uh if
you want to follow us on twitter
it's at the mm podcast
on twitter all right and all the videos
that i recommend and all the [__] that i
talk about
i'll definitely uh
have the links up there it's way more
organized than it ever used to be all
right
there you go uh bill a bunch of emails
from people who are at the taping couple
emails
calling out douchebags at the first show
for being loud you know i didn't mind
that you know the first show they told
everybody to stay in their seats
and um we realized that that was wrong
because i was doing well over an hour
and people were drinking they had they
had to go to the bathroom it wasn't fair
so um
so in the second show i was i just said
to the people you know who are shooting
the thing like look people walk around
all the [__] time i still have a good
set
i don't give a [__] just let them do
what they want to do i don't you know
let's just make it more like a show and
that's what we did and the second show
went even better so anyways
all right bill in response to male [__]
versus a female [__]
um all right dear billy buffalo
i am a proud woman who loves other women
nice
i found your handling of the [__] gay
son verse a [__] for a daughter
question to be spot on i also agree
agree with the gay man who wrote in last
week if i was sitting around a table and
this question was posed you know what's
funny i don't even remember what i said
i'd feel it was addressing current
issues that are generally ignored
discussions that are usually avoided in
fear of discrimination but in actuality
depriving important dialogue yeah
absolutely
you should be allowed
to be ignorant
islam you know as long as you're not
like acting on it like trying to hurt
somebody you should be allowed to say
the things that you feel
and if they they end up being
um
you know i
ignorant not being dumb just ignorant
like you just weren't exposed to some
other information you got to have people
get them out
and then
that's how you move on to the next level
like now actually it's like this oh i
didn't know that
and then you know hopefully
you change for the better
um so anyways discussions that are
usually blah blah blah blah
she says i never knew my father but i
would hope he would answer that question
honestly frankly i don't like labeling
either as [__] but it's the easiest
way to sum it up i i agree with you
wholeheartedly
uh calling somebody a [__] yeah that's
really bad
a hoe's kind of funny [__] to actually
say it [__]
is really bad um
she continues to say i'd be remiss not
to mention that nia spoke emotionally as
a straight woman but did not consider
why the question is important to gay
children oftentimes gay teens
experiment prematurely after having
repressed feelings for their early
for their early adolescence
or from their early adolescence i don't
know the truth is though emotional
emotional changes and repercussions of
early sexual encounters affect the
female
much more severely this is not to say
that boys can't suffer the effects but
as you and mia have both pointed out in
the past women are more sensitive to
certain things that men are not
i was with you all away until till um
where you say that the uh the sexual
encounters affect the female much more
severely
um i don't think that that's something
you could ever prove or disprove
like that's something that i always go
round and round with my wife with when
somebody says you know it's easier for
guys to lose weight
you know i it's like well you would have
to be a guy
okay and then be a woman and then live
the exact same life and eat the exact
same food to really sit there
and try and guess
if if whatever is easier and whatever i
mean i think it all kind of balances
itself out as far as easy and difficult
it's like you know
i don't know that just that whole
[__] reoccurring thing that
this is a bad experience but it's worse
for women
or this is this experience it's easier
for guys it's just always like
there has to be something out there
where it's even or there has to be
something out there where it's worse or
aren't they both it's just kind of a big
[__] sandwich out there and the big game
is you know
trying to block that out isn't it
i would actually say
that uh
the guy's pain
is that we are not allowed to
talk about our pain
at all where you guys can have painful
[__] happen to you and it's okay for you
literally to break down sobbing
and weeping which is so healthy for you
to get it out
to get it out of you
i mean it doesn't get it all out of you
but it gets that
the build up the the like
you know you have a cook oatmeal and you
walk away and you leave it too high and
it [__] boils over yeah that [__] you
can get that off
i think
through crying
like the funny thing about crying is it
is a natural emotion for both men and
women but we're told that we can't do it
and uh it's a [__] horrible thing
um
it's a horrible thing so i'm not saying
that that makes you guys have it easier
but i'm just saying that that is that is
something that i don't think that uh
is taken into consideration and i just
feel like you know every time i see the
you know i
that's a recurrent thing but i i agree
with everything else that you're saying
i guess you probably think i'm a dick
now but i'm just
i'm just saying that you know like
um i don't know if you're a guy and you
know you got to cry
but you don't want to embarrass yourself
just go take a shower
nobody's going to notice no one's going
to hear you and if somebody were to rip
back the [__] thing the the the
shower curtain like in psycho you could
just act like you got shampoo in your
eye just don't start talking or else
they'll realize it but you know just
have your head under the water and just
sort of look at them like what i'm
showering get away from me you weirdo
um
yeah you can cry out a lot of childhood
pain as a guy in in the in the shower
without anybody knowing
all right dear billy ginger nuts
jesus christ can you [__] you know
can you come at me from a different
goddamn angle everything's red hair red
pubes [__] pasty i got it you think i
haven't heard this my whole [__] life
jesus [__] christ
yeah i i gotta hand it to you guys you
know you have found 700 different
[__] ways to attack me
i'm referring to the question raised
uh whether it would be better to have a
daughter who jesus christ this [__]
question really has been living on
whether it would be better to have a
daughter who were a [__] or a gay son
who was also a [__] the best analogy
i've ever heard with respect to the
whole
why is it deemed bad for a female to be
a [__] but not a male is this if you
own a key that opens uh opens lots of
locks
then that that is pretty cool but if you
have a
a lock that is opened by a lot
of keys then that is a shitty lock
you know it would have helped if i read
it better if you own a key that opens
lots of locks that's pretty cool but if
you have a lock that is open by a lot of
keys then that is a shitty luck i
actually i don't like that one
i like my analogy because i'm a
self-centered [__]
i just think it doesn't take any [__]
skill
the love the skill level for a woman
to get laid
is is just like what do you have to do
lay on your back spread your legs who
wants it i'm not saying you're gonna get
somebody desirable
you know
but the [__] work we there's
something to try this one time i told
you i did this with my wife
where uh you just turned the tables one
night have her hit on you
have her come up with an opening line
you watch you watch how much they bomb
you watch the flop sweat they they got
nothing
you think you have nothing they it when
it comes to that [__] most of them are
are like their game is where your game
was when you were like 12 13 the first
few times you were trying to talk
to some girl in your grade you got
nothing because you never tried it
before that's where they're at
at like 35.
um
anyways free billy hey there you go
a little play on the movie title uh
billy four times congrats on the
completion of your fourth special i
can't wait to watch you with my friends
we will all crowd around the tv like one
of the roosevelt's fireside chats look
at this person a free willy
reference
and then uh has hit me with a little bit
of uh depression error [__]
uh my question
to you is how will you celebrate beers
burgers
uh what do the coming weeks have in
store for you please don't say working
on your next hour because no one likes a
goody two shoes
yeah you know why because you're still
[__] up in your life all right you
know what's funny is i opened this
podcast talking about this um
i am going to drink but i also i don't
put on the weight that i took off
for this special you know
i'm looking good for me
all right and uh i actually have started
this new workout
i found this dude on on uh
youtube i [__] i think i told you guys
about him last week
this guy uh
frank madrano
frank madrano fitness this guy he's a
vegan
and all he does is uh his own body
weight he's absolutely [__] shredded
shredded so um
i'm gonna try to you know i've been
eating a lot more vegetarian but i still
you know i'm one of those guys i mean
there's no [__] way
you know i'm still gonna have a couple
of steaks a month
but
i'd like to try to eliminate a lot of
that other
i don't know a lot of that you know what
i this is what i liked about eating
vegetarian for two i would try to go two
days a week
and it was hard man at first
you don't know what to eat you don't
know where to go you don't know how to
make anything it sucks but
uh the cool thing about eating
vegetarian i would go back to back days
just eating all veggie what was great
was it affected my eating the other five
days
because it really it like resets your
cravings
and i'm telling you man like when i get
into that [__] sugar salt thing
like back in the day i would go on like
i don't know i would go on like a two
and a half month bender of just eating
poorly i would still you know take my
dog on hikes and stuff so i i never
really let it get too bad but in that
two and a half months i put on like
[__] 10 pounds 15 pounds or something
like that then i'm just oh [__] i got to
try to get this [__] off
and
um that great thing about
or even just one meal a day if you just
do it all veggie it it [__] balances
you out
and you stop riding that roller coaster
sugar salt sugar salt sugar salt and i
[__] hate going to the gym i [__] i
don't like working out i mean i like it
but i i don't i don't like having to do
it because i'm a tub of [__]
and um
i can't recommend it enough
if you if you just start eating that way
dude if you go veggie two days a week
and you go for a walk ride a bike or do
something like that the fats got nowhere
to hide
it's got nowhere to go
it has to [__] leave
you know and then if you're just sort of
decent
the rest of the week
you know and i tell you you know
i still i'll i'll [__] i'll crush a
pizza i'll order a [__]
i'll order a pizza and a [__] slam
that i'll make cupcakes like the twinkle
toes that i am and i don't eat a bunch
of those in that type of [__] but then i
do the two veggie
days in a row and all of that it settles
down again like it's almost like a fire
it doesn't get out of control so that
has been working for me
and uh i've been doing the pull-ups
climbing the rope and the dips and the
push-ups and uh
i just like that type at this point in
my life i just like doing that better
than uh throwing the weights around
but i'll always still like doing that
because i came of age in the 80s
and that was always fun you know
benching
so what am i gonna do um
i i'm gonna i'm gonna [__] party with
the all-in guys smoke some cigars but uh
i am i'm not a goody two shoes what i am
is i'm somebody who [__] i already
lived the life dude
i did all of that okay and uh
i'm too [__] old to keep to keep
putting on 15 20 pounds and try and take
him off i don't want to look like the
[__] horror show that i saw at the
beach today i don't want to be those
people
all right i don't want to be sitting
there with my [__] shirt off with my
tits staring at my [__] toes
you know eating a
a bag of crisps i don't [__] be that
guy
all right you can do that in your 20s
have at it and you can wake up the next
day and still [__] be in shape but i
can't do it at my age so uh
there you go
um
i don't know i rode a motorcycle today
that's about the dumbest [__] thing
you could ever do so is that enough for
you
um okay bill will the military hurt my
comedy career
um hi bill i'm an 18 year old stand-up
comedian in atlanta georgia i started
when i was 17 and so far i enjoy it
while it can be shitty at times
however i've always wanted to join the
military when i was young and still do
to this day i've been considering
joining the army and trying to become a
green beret for a long time now after i
finish college
uh this isn't a decision i made because
i played a couple games of call of duty
and thought it was cool i've just always
wanted to do something exciting and
adventurous i realize it is very hard to
become one
uh oh yeah i watched that thing on
netflix
and and that was a that wasn't to be a
green beret that was to be like an army
ranger or something like that i forget
what it was called like 11 days of hell
it was [__] brutal
um anyways he said i realize it's very
hard to become one and there's a chance
i might not make it but i am pretty much
training every day and still have
another four years however if i were to
pursue this goal it would also mean i
will not be able to do stand up until i
am about 28 or 30. i would like to
continue with stand-up comedy once i get
back
but i am worried that i might be a
little too old to start by then any
suggestions
jesus christ uh
well first of all um being a comedian is
also an exciting life and an adventurous
life
and um
i guess it all depends on what type of
adventure that you want to have
um
i mean becoming a green beret is pretty
[__] badass and that is a very very
very small
uh
i guess club to be a member of
um
you know so i would never say
don't do i mean those [__] guy i mean
if they're unbelievable
they're [__] unreal i mean those
those stupid action movies
these actors flipping over cars and
everything i mean like the true like
action like those navy seals the the
green berets the army rangers i mean
those guys are there are [__]
unbelievable so i mean that's a
um i gotta be honest with you i don't
you know
i don't see any regret on either one of
those because
i would just whatever whatever one you
want to do more i would look the great
thing is you got four years to get
through college before you have to make
this decision so i would continue doing
stand up i continue doing your workout
and um
you know in four years just figure out
you know you got four years to figure
out which one you want to do but i can't
give you advice like that as far as uh
you're 28 or 30
um
yeah i mean that's later than most
people but you're already doing it now
and you can also do it all the way
through college
and there's nothing stopping you from
doing it while you're in the military on
your your
your weekends off or some [__] like that
um
all right let's just say if you actually
got into the military and you didn't get
out
until you were 28 or 30
i would say uh
if that's the situation you were in what
i would do is i would just look at
comedians that started late and made it
and that's who i would focus on
um i've always done that
i didn't always do that i learned to do
that so i stayed positive
you know what i mean
um
and it really is
like the the i i the business that i'm
in
the worst thing that you can do is give
you know the other people the power
mentally
to just be like well i'm too old they
don't want me you start thinking that
way then they don't you just [__]
you go out there you do your [__]
and
it's it's really uh it yeah like even
the way you're looking at this and the
way i i just realized this now like it's
not what the [__] can you not walk on a
stage and take a mic out of a mic stand
at 28 or 30 you're gonna be a goddamn
green beret
jesus christ you're probably repelling
from a [__] helicopter and come
through the ceiling
um
of course you can
of course you can you can [__] do it
because what it really is is it what
you're doing then is you're becoming an
artist
um and then all that is is that's just
your own personal journey and you're
just trying to keep becoming a better
artist and all that other [__] crap
um comes
you know and if you just keep working on
yourself
and trying to get better and better and
better and better eventually you become
undeniable and they gotta let you in
that's basically what it is or you just
go out and you make your own [__] who
gives a [__]
and then they'll come over to you hey
what are you making over there i'm
making this stuff okay we'd like to be
involved all right what's the deal well
we're gonna own it hey go [__] yourself
oh okay
um it's been my experience
yeah dude so you got four years so i
would i would continue working out and
keep doing the stand up in four years
four years is a long time when you're
only 18 years old so uh see what you
think in the end but uh those are two
very noble
um
you know uh uh goals
to try to achieve
i'm not gonna lie to you i watched that
11 days of hell and just i mean i was
just wondering if if
you know
just to see if i can make it through it
i've got to be mentally tough enough
forget about physically the mental wear
down of those [__] guys yelling at
you and the impossible situations that
they put you in both as an individual
and then in the group dynamic
it's just it's unbelievable 11 straight
[__] days of that
um i would love to do that but i i don't
i don't know i'm enough of a [__]
psycho i i wouldn't need to
to uh
to be in the military if you know what i
mean you know
especially when we're at war the last
[__] thing i need to do
is break one of the only commandments i
haven't broken yet
because i don't know that i would come
back i don't know that i'm
mentally strong enough that if i went to
that [__] place that i could somehow
come back
uh
i don't know i'm out of my [__] mind
so i i have a tremendous amount of
respect for anybody who successfully
becomes a soldier and can handle the
demands that are put on you all right
okay here we go catholic girlfriend
hey aaron burr
sorry if that history reference was a
little too high brow
oh you [__] what do you mean high brow
like you'd be like i don't know who that
is
wha hi bro you know what i'm not even
gonna take that person because you can
be making fun of the listeners or making
fun of yourself i have no [__] idea
um i love aaron burr and he was right
okay and hamilton's a [__] he knew what
he was getting himself involved in and
he [__] lost
[__] crybaby now he's on the ten
dollar bill where's aaron burr everybody
hates him because he won you know he's
like the original kobe
um sorry if that history reference was a
little too high brow but aaron burr was
essentially the biggest [__]
in the early united states
history small world right
i would love to hear you justify that he
was
he was one of the biggest [__] how
about the people out there who were
committing genocide on the native
americans
what did he do he was a dick at dinner
parties
agreed to have a duel and had to [__]
balls
to walk out there and he wins
because hamilton was cheating he [__]
quick whatever they did they he quick
cocked his [__] gun so when he
brought it up it was already he did some
to try to do some little shady [__]
move before he brought it up straight it
sh it fired
so [__] him
i'm [__] real
i'm [__] real do you realize if aaron
burr [__] lost he would be on the 10
bill and then you would have said that
hamilton's the biggest [__]
who the [__] would you be you'd be
talking to that guy in the rangers
um anyways i've been seeing this girl
for around six months now and i'm
seriously nuts about her i love spending
time with her and can see this
relationship even leading to a ring in a
few years oh congratulations but the big
problem for me is we're not having sex
she's very religious which does not oh
she's very religious which does not
bother me because she doesn't care that
i'm not
ostensibly i don't know what the [__]
that means
um
you know what why don't i look that word
up
you guys you want me to take a guess
here
even though i'm not ostensibly
i you know i can't even guess what the
[__] that means
what does that mean you go twice a year
can i even spell it
uh s st
well there it is
it figured it out thank you computer
apparently or purportedly but perhaps
not actually
you know what go for this is why why why
do you try to become smart when that's
the [__] answer
um you know that that's a great line to
give a cop
you've been drinking tonight
apparently or purportedly but perhaps
not actually
[__] flashlight to the head
um to all outward appearances
okay
so i guess that's a fancy way of saying
apparently is this guy a hipster and
he's sick of all the hipsters saying
apparently
um where am i
because she does not
wait let me read this now now that i i
just learned what ostensibly means which
okay
but the big problem for me is we're not
having sex she's very religious which
doesn't bother me because she doesn't
doesn't care that i'm not
ostensibly
and i have to go back and look it up
again i i don't understand what this
means
to all outward appearances you're not
religious
is this like some fancy way of saying
that you're mysterious
anyways it's her choice and it didn't
bother me for a while but i guess my
[__] hormones are starting to get the
better of me we're both in college right
now and come from different backgrounds
she does community service
and i'm a frat [__] i'd break it off
if i didn't feel as strongly about her
as i do but i'm not sure how much longer
i can put up with
my most intimate partner being pornhub
and a bottle of lotion should i tell her
how i feel or just quit being a selfless
bastard uh selfish bastard are my
concerns normal or am i being a [__] um
first of all you're not a frat [__]
if you actually have empathy as far as
the stereotype goes you're actually a
very mature person you seem like you
know what what you have and you don't
want to lose it
um
uh how do you say i respect your uh
your religious views but
how does the bearded baby feel about the
occasional hand job over there
does she know that you're watching i
tell you it's not a good thing to only
be watching porn and not having sex with
somebody uh
i don't know are you starting to become
more of a serial killer i have no idea
hey nia
you know what i i gotta i gotta bring
nia in for this one
i gotta bring her in for this one hang
on one second let me hit pause here
i know i hit pause
all right the lovely nia everybody hello
all right here we go um
here is the question so this kid he's
basically i'm gonna paraphrase here so
the listeners don't have to listen to it
again
uh he's got a catholic girlfriend
um
she's very religious just pull the
microphone back you're breathing into it
there sorry sorry i think i had turned
up too much
um
anyways uh you know this
catholic girl very religious does not
want to have sex before marriage okay
and
he's saying you know they've been
together for a while he
loves her spending time with her you can
see actually given her ring in a couple
of years but the big problem is they're
not having sex she's very religious um
he's not religious but she doesn't care
he said it's her choice and you know to
not have sex and it didn't bother me for
a while but i guess my [__] hormones
are starting to get the better of me
we're both in college right now and i
come from different backgrounds she does
community service and i'm a frat boy
[__]
or a frat [__] he said i'd break it
off
if i didn't feel as strongly about her
as i do but i'm not sure how much longer
i can put up with my most intimate
partner being pornhub in a bottle of
lotion should i tell her how i feel or
just
quit being a selfish bastard are my
concerns normal or am i being a [__]
no you're not being a [__]
i think he's actually being really
great that's what i thought yeah i mean
you should definitely tell your
girlfriend but be prepared but don't
how does he do it because what i would
what i would if i was in that situation
i would try to say you know it's you
know it's just a hand
job it's just a handy just a handy man
no i think you should tell her how he's
feeling but i would just walk out with
my dad are you gonna keep interrupting
me can you help me out always
that sounds like something you would do
actually and you um yeah she'd laugh um
no i mean you tell her how you feel but
don't frame it in the context like i'm
[__] dying over here what are you
doing to me oh my god don't make it like
a guilt trip just say just just so you
know i'm i'm really having
a hard time with this because i love you
so much and i really want to have sex
with you but i know you don't want to i
don't want to pressure you make love
rather than sex well however you want to
fight love is gross no it's not is it
it's gross make love yeah i mean i don't
know it's gross
it's just it's very like old-fashioned
it's like what you say when you're
trying to like be nice about it or
something you know yeah [__] you don't
want to say that
that's my favorite line in the movie
what tim robbins and bull durham we
gonna [__] or what oh yeah
is that where that's from yeah
um but yeah just just tell her and the
thing is she probably feels the same way
she might be frustrated
put her on a noob
give me that becky
she's been listening to this southern
rap
white and black people in in the south
they pronounce in certain words they
just pronounce the beginning with first
couple of letters yeah you drop off like
if it if a word
it has like two like syllables you gotta
just do the first one look at here
it's all on the new
uh but anyway yeah just just just be
honest with her about it but but just
you know make it clear that she knows
how much you love and respect her and
that's that's all you can do but how
does he do it without
her
feeling pressure she might feel pressure
she probably already feels pressure from
society or whatever so you know she's
already feeling the pressure but so
should he sit there and be like listen
i'm not trying to put any pressure on
you i'm just telling you
where i'm at
because if he keeps going to pornhub
what happens is with porn is you have to
keep going further and further and
further down the [__] hallway and
when they finally have sex she's going
to be like what what do you want me to
do right
you know she's going to be freaked out
because that's the other thing you watch
too much porn and like porn becomes like
your reality about what everyday
relationship sex is no there's all kinds
of it's like it's i don't know i mean
obviously it can't be for everybody but
it's like be careful with that porn [__]
because it's awesome but it'll really
like put you on another planet if you're
not careful about it and you just start
thinking like people should be
performing like porn stars and you
should be performing like porn stars you
should be able to do all these crazy
[__] these people are paid to have sex
that's their job that's not your job so
just just i don't know just be careful
with that i just feel like
it's like what the [__] he supposed to
do though
this is the thing keep masturbating
yeah i know thank god i wasn't around
when i was [__] that age jesus christ
how did you watch porn at that age you
like sneak old vcr tapes from your older
brother like um
no no
nobody had a porno in my house no
[__] way we had one vcr in the family
room
it was impossible i used to sneak and
watch uh do you remember uh emmanuel it
was like this softcore
like cinemax show it was like from
europe
it was from europe and it was all like
soft lighting it was all about this girl
emmanuel who would have these like sexy
adventures like she's going on a train
to paris and then like she looks over
and you know she and the guy like bang
in the [__]
i don't know
[Laughter]
literally and figuratively
now uh the first time i saw porno uh
a buddy of mine had it
buddy of mine got one
and we were all on our way out and like
five of us just sat there and watched it
yeah
and then just got up and went out how
old are you
like 17. i watched the porn out of
sleepover but we were like in eighth
grade or something like she stole it
from her dad and it was like a 70s porn
it's always just great everyone's hairy
and it was just disgusting like it was
the one the one that i saw
freaking me out the one that i saw i
swear to god
i swear to god this happened okay the
dude who was he he was working at a
restaurant
you know and he was getting laid and
he's [__] everybody and they had this
[__] old ugly lady comes in and was
giving him [__] uh-huh
you know make the chicken sandwich and i
want extra mayo on it oh god oh no no
this is even worse
instead of just having the guy jerk off
onto the [__] sandwich i swear to god
you know a rotisserie chicken yeah you
know you can just buy one that's already
made yeah he [__] it oh my god this
wasn't a porno yeah
what see nowadays that that would have
been considered
bestiality no it was considered like
they were trying to be it was and they
were trying to be like funny because
they played like there's
a wake up regularly this wacky music
when he was doing it right and i was
like i you gotta understand i had never
seen a [__] porno and it went like
the first time you saw and especially
back then
where it was like uh like the most
overtly like sexual thing like when i
was a kid was brooke shields
with the one button
on her shirt right i went from that to
watching people actually [__] and
then this dude stuck his dick in a
chicken that's disgusting remember when
we went to go see that um what's that
quentin tarantino it was grind house it
was like the two movies and then in
between they had the fake trailers and
one of them was thugs
and then they showed their quick little
like two second thing at the end of it
was a guy like [__] a turkey remember
and then everyone in the movie theater
went oh
because they just threw it in like super
quick
i would not be surprised if they got
that idea from that very porno that you
watched yeah because
because i think eli roth directed that
like trailer that fake trailer or
something but
yeah that's disgusting yeah like we're
not like then and i remember like the
videos then after that the video store
came out and then the video store it had
the back room with ours it had those so
funny they had these saloon doors you
had to walk through
and then to get into the back room and
there wasn't i remember being like a
beaded curtain in some areas like that
was like the sexy area it was where the
beauty curtain was and i had to it was
so early on
i don't think that there was categories
they just had porno right it was all
straight porn yeah
growing up in a suburb right
it was just all
straight porn there was no there was no
like categories like uh
you know whatever [__] doggy style
ones or or like or like it's more like i
feel like it's like race or why sexual
identity like asian porn you're asian
it was just people [__] on camera
that's all it was that's it it was a man
and a woman [__] or a man and two
women [__] or two guys [__] a
woman and that was in the occasional and
then the chicken thing was a bit like it
was supposed to be this funny thing
and i it was funny
because it was the first one i ever saw
like i i was sitting like what the [__]
right
um
but then i was also psyched because i
actually saw some i actually saw a porno
a woman getting bagged and [__] and it
wasn't until years later
like wait a minute i think i was hanging
out i was still living with uh bobby
kelly and we were talking about the
first corners they're the first pornos
that we saw
i remember telling that he was just
going what i go dude i swear to god
he goes what was his name i don't know
what the name it was my buddy just had
it
but you know you know who would know you
know who would know the answer to it is
david david he would know i bet if you
asked him or if we tweeted him and said
do you remember ever seeing a porno from
circa whatever year that is and a guy if
i bet he would know it
you realize you just blew up his twitter
account oh no
um all right we're gonna end with this
uh dilemma oh wait you know i gotta read
some i gotta read the rest of the
advertising real quick uh hulu plus
everybody
come on let me read it here hulu plus
she probably tried hulu on your computer
hulu plus is so much more hulu with hulu
plus you can watch current season
episodes of your favorite shows like
modern family the daily show and scandal
and watch every episode of shows like
nashville lost and doctor who
um you get ad-free movies and kid shows
too now more than ever there is so much
to watch take total control with hulu
plus to stream these shows and thousands
more as much as you want whenever you
want this is the best part hulu plus
works on your computer your smart tv
roku apple tv xbox playstation pretty
much any streaming device you already
own you can apply hulu plus to you can
even watch on your eye on your phone or
ipad
while on the train at work at the
dentist or in the bathroom you can even
block off a day to binge
you also get access to originals that
you can get anywhere that you can't get
anywhere else check out the new show
deadbeat a comedy about a pot smoking
guy who talks to ghosts binge on all 10
episodes starting april 9th for only
7.99 a month get uh get your shows
anytime anywhere that's like a quarter a
day right now sign up for huluplus.com
norm for some reason they keep giving me
this one
yeah let's get norm let's let's give
norm mcdonald the [__] money this
week
hulu.com
norm and get two weeks full access
completely free that's a whole week
whole extra week more with your special
offer when you sign up at huluplus.com
norm
so get with it and start streaming tv
now with hulu plus
and lastly but not leastly
stamps.com everyone sama is finally here
and you want as much free time as
possible don't let going to the post
office cut into that free time everybody
just use stamps.com instead with
stamps.com you can print postage right
from your desk you won't ever have to go
to the office post office again find
parking wait your turn all of that stuff
that you hate stamps.com turns your pc
or your mac into your own personal post
office what can you do with it well you
can buy and print official us postage
using your computer and printer you can
print everything from stamps to shipping
labels shipping labels whenever you need
it then just hand your mail to the
mailman boom you're done stamps.com is
so convenient and easy to use even a
[__] like me can use it you'll never
waste time going to the post office
again i use this to send out all my dvds
all my posters whatever crap i'm selling
at the end i've never had a problem i'm
an idiot if i can figure it out so can
you there's no reason to go to the post
office anymore and right now use my last
name bird burr for this special offer no
risk trial plus 110 bonus offer includes
a digital scale and up to 55 dollars
free postage so don't wait go to
stamps.com before you do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur bur that's
stamps.com enter burr that was a pretty
good read huh
yeah you're getting better at those get
better at him
um i'm still [__] up and i'm getting
better
uh dilemma hey bill would you rather be
morbidly obese to the point where just
walking around is exhausting
i'm talking over 350 pounds
and you weren't allowed to lose the
weight i love that you already answered
or
would you rather be stuck in prison for
the rest of your life oh god second
present
really that's how shallow i am
hilarious
um
i feel like though
oh my sorry i feel like though if you're
350 pounds or whatever that's my fault
by the way i'm not good with the mixer
oh okay uh it's like you're already in
prison you're imprisoned in your own
body
i think they're both prisons aren't they
yeah i mean they are but i mean it's
like
oh i see what you mean
no no i'm agreeing with you yeah you
just had a nice little metaphor there
and i ruined it
um
would i rather be obese or be in prison
for the rest it's a no-brainer
yeah i'd rather yeah i yeah
just like but i can't just think of the
fun you'd have getting that fat
that's the thing it would be really fun
to just be like eating all the good [__]
that you can't have in prison they don't
have good food there so maybe i would
rather be obese
i don't know
jesus christ do you imagine somebody
obese listening to this right now
they're basically you're basically
saying gee i would rather be in prison
for the rest of my life than be you i'd
definitely rather be it's not about your
personality you know what and this is a
silly like objective thing that's never
going to get on a plane we can talk
about it and people shouldn't get
offended by it you can get on plane
with your two seats and your giant seat
belt yeah and you can fly anywhere in
the [__] world
and go get even fatter right
do you have to buy two seats if you're
like over a certain weight what's the
weight requirement now yeah but whatever
it is like like kevin smith is over it
right because that's how why he got
he had that whole problem with jetblue
or southwest because they thought
southwest southwest because they were
like yeah you need to buy
i didn't think he was that big though
like two seats big i don't know i've
never met him
i met him he wasn't two seats big when i
saw yeah i don't know maybe they're just
being dicks
look the only time southwest is a
southwest is a great airline but i don't
like uh i don't like all the jokes that
they tell
i get it that they're trying to make it
lighten it up and we're the cool company
but it's like my life is in your hands
right now and i would i would i would
you mean i thought you meant the
stewards even that i don't like being i
don't like it either i've kind of
because this is this is what i find
i find when you go in someplace if the
person at the top
is doing their job right everybody
beneath is also in line and they come
off like they're out of line okay it
seems
like the the vibe
on a southwest flight is that there's a
substitute teacher i don't like that you
know what i mean i like i like feeling
like [__] is in order
you know have you seen on virgin
airlines the um their safety video is
like this full-scale music video
production [__] thing there's like a
little kid that raps in it there's like
a little asian girl that robs a little
black kid that's wearing a suit that's
like and there's break dancers and you
can't get away from it it's a whole you
can't get away from me i was actually
like i was actually finding myself happy
for the people that were in the video
that they were got work and exposure on
this level and i was impressed by it i
was like how much money does richard
branson have he really made i hate the
mood like and they have and they have a
behind the like behind the scenes video
of how they made the thing on it so what
i'm saying what are you saying you hate
the move lighting where on virgin why
what do you mean you walk on you're just
looking you're gonna get an std when you
get on the [__] thing i love virgin
airlines i love it i don't mind it like
virgin's cool i i don't i jetblue's cool
jetblue is good you get to watch espn
the whole way across the country i like
that yeah i like being able to watch all
my stupid like bravo real housewives the
only the only airline i really don't
[__] like other than the just the
crazy ones that i used to fly when i was
starting out like that
was it ata or some [__]
oh um i don't know
all trans
something transparent um yeah yeah yeah
you know how many airlines i've flown
that don't even [__] exist anymore at
this point just got swallowed up
uh i flew people's express in the 80s
what is that ugh it was like the
precursor to value jet man i was [__]
shady i remember value jet yeah um they
had that fire um
unfortunately uh you know what i'm sorry
i need to go back i'm i would rather be
obese eastern airline
might but yeah my mom used to work for
eastern she used to fly she was a twa
uh-huh north west
none of these exist anymore none of them
they either got bought out or they went
out of business uh
wait can we go back i should fly frank's
airline can we go back to that sounds
like like a corner store like a place
for like a double franks like a deli
yeah
i would rather
i made that up i would rather be
obese and free
than in prison exactly and can we
apologize to people who are overweight
yeah and you know what yeah absolutely
you know we're not apologizing we're in
the age of apologizing take a [__]
joke fatty but
you and you're fat shaving but you know
what the fat shaming
shame shame american
[Music]
i wouldn't want to be i wouldn't want to
be in prison that was that was a
stupid answer i said that that was my
vain answer we got it
but i admit that hey i wanna i wanna
start a new segment on here where i fat
shame somebody every week because i know
because i make it work why don't you
shame other people too can you shame
like just shame can i finish across the
board can i finish here sure so mother
jingle's gonna say that chain of fools
where they go chain chain chain i'm
gonna go shame shame shame boo boo boo
boo boo yeah another song shame on you
oh no then i'll have somebody sing the
high part you ate those cupcakes
you really are just going to go with
this idea no you're not yeah yeah we are
i'm waiting i'm going to show that they
used to do that on the news they used to
do this [__] remember and they'd have
this like graphic of a finger pointing
and it was the reporters that would be
like they would go up to like
did they used to be bad no they had
their own they had their own little like
jingle bell i'm telling you is that
yeah they would like burst into places
and say i hear you know we hear that
you're charging customers for
don't you think that's wrong and they'd
have to like get the owners to try to
like fess up that's right and then the
graphic would come and be like boom yeah
and it was like it wasn't it was a
finger like wagging and that was that
was it i don't know if there's religious
nuts out there that can try to like make
gay people straight
and they're trying to show like that
they think that that works right
aren't i kind of like those people where
i think shaming
i've actually had i've had that's what
they do on the biggest loser i thought
when they scream at them
and make them cry and make them puke
i can't believe someone just hasn't
dropped of a heart attack i know
they've been writing articles about that
show and how it's really [__] up you
know i watch i used to watch it all the
time because i was like i found a video
and you'd sit there and cry with them
laugh
you did a bit about it i remember
because that's what you were that's when
you were talking about how like they had
so much fun like they're living the life
they're they're the real rock stars
because while you're sitting there like
you know eating salads and having to
work out they're just like doing
whatever they want and living the life
oh my god that's right that was a while
that was a while ago when you did that
bit but
i used to love that show after a while i
was like all right i get it i get it i'm
over it but no i really i really liked
it but people have a serious problem i
thought the woman left the show because
she was sick of jillian she was sick of
them
sweating all over
she made her money and she's back
i think that last season she's been back
she left for a little everybody's back
yeah this business is shrinking by the
day there was all movie stars
all the movie stars are doing tv shows
now
i know i want to watch that halle berry
tv show i need to watch the pilot just
commercials
and so people are grabbing
every dime they can get
before my business turns into what the
music industry did do you realize how
[__] lucky i am that i can i actually
have a live show that i can go on the
road how lucky i am thank [__] christ
but do you think like live shows are
gonna be something of the past because
it's like
they've been going on forever and ever
no no no i think people will always want
to do that i mean maybe they'll uh
you know be funny as if
as if somehow like what do they call
those things they did that creepy thing
with tupac and michael jackson oh the
hologram [__] that they're doing like at
coachella and like award shows where
like yeah all of a sudden tupac shows up
and does like his entire discography so
it's a bunch of people tripping their
balls off
i know right
and people you'd hear people when you
see footage on youtube people being like
i knew it i knew it was alive i knew and
then they're like oh wait it's a
hologram
jesus well i would never say that that
wouldn't happen but
i would think at some point
you're going to want to leave the house
you're going to want to have to leave
the [__] house but i i gotta be
honest with you what are you talking
about
like live shows if people like live
shows would stop i will tell you this
though i love
that movie i did walk of shame how at
this it's simultaneously released
on
i would see more movies if i could just
sit on my ass here
and pop in godzilla or some [__] like
that i definitely would and godzilla is
something that i didn't go see but if i
was sitting at home i would [__]
watch that [__] we still need to go see
maleficent is it still in the movie
theater i want to see that movie yeah i
did and now i don't i was because they
stopped showing commercials and i
stopped giving a [__] like i was into it
like they got me they had me left and
i'll go see that alice in wonderland
looking evil witch [__] i'll go see that
don't wait snow white in the
seven dwarfs
right it's about the evil queen but yeah
yeah yeah exactly that was her
perspective when we had angelina is the
uh she's she's a maleficent she's the
queen and we had her wrong the whole
time well we get to understand what
happened to her and the whole bit and
why she's that way
can i tell you something about that evil
which
she her child tell me about it because
her childhood was a long time ago okay
at some point it happens in your 30s
okay you have to stop taking your
childhood out on people and you got a
[__] man up
okay so that's what i would say to that
witch okay can we please go see this
movie so we can talk about it then is
she's standing there stirring her
[__] steel
[__] pot whatever the hell she's
doing with bat heads in it cauldron all
right listen this podcast is going on
and on and on and on
we gotta wrap it up we gotta wrap it up
all right this is this has been the
monday morning podcast thanks
say thanks for everybody uh for
listening um thanks everybody seriously
who came out
um
to my uh stand-up special you can tell
i'm pretty [__] burned out from the
whole weekend uh i i really appreciate
it i had a great time going down that
land is such a great comedy city and uh
yay atl yeah i had a great [__] time
so that's it i'm gonna work on the new
hour hopefully i'll have enough of that
[__] together by the time the special
comes out i'll let you guys know when
that comes out
you